today the matt walsh show the outrage
mob is coming after me because i
mentioned the forbidden historical fact
that white people were slaves too but
why is this fact forbidden and why does
it matter we'll discuss also the by
administration gears up to forgive
student loans and by forgive we mean
transfer the loans to people who didn't
take them out plus a democrat
congresswoman flips off her republican
colleagues and then cries sexism to
excuse herself and our daily
cancellation an artist goes viral with
dozens of comics
bitterly complaining about her husband
we'll talk about all that and much more
today on the matt welsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today's world is a scary one too many
people don't seem to care about the
truth moral standards have flown out the
window and i'd argue that that's all
rooted in people becoming anti-religious
that's why it's more important than ever
that we take a step back from all this
craziness and keep our relationships
with god strong and intact the best way
to do that is by praying every day with
hallo hallow is the number one christian
prayer app in the u.s it's like calm or
head space but it's rooted in catholic
faith as opposed to the religion of
leftism hallow offers over 5 000 audio
guided prayers meditations and christian
music tracks some of the most popular
prayers include the daily rosary uh the
gospel reading and daily psalm with
bishop barron prayers are led by a lot
of people you would recognize mark
wahlberg mario lopez jim kavisel and
they've got minute meditations they've
got prayers for kids which is really
important get your kids involved and
much more hello helps me find peace and
calm throughout the day even as crazy
leftists yell at me through a tiny
screen still they cannot destroy my
peace because of hello so let hello help
you find your peace and strength um and
also strengthen your faith go to
hallow.com matt walsh or text pray to
1-855-944-5684 and get an extended
three-month trial for free during which
you'll have access to over 5000
meditations and pairs that's hallow.com
matt walsh or text pray to
1-855-944-5684
for three months for you reclaim your
peace in this crazy world download hallo
today
you know over the weekend i finished the
book skeletons on the zahara it tells
the story of james riley captain of the
merchant ship commerce which shipwrecked
off the coast of north africa in 1815
riley along with his entire crew found
themselves stranded in the vast saharan
desert where they began to die from
thirst and exposure almost immediately
that was only the beginning of their
troubles of course the men were soon
seized and enslaved by a band of desert
nomads
and from that point the crew was split
off in different directions as each man
was sold and traded from one nomad to
the next they were abused starved beaten
found themselves on a hierarchy where
white slaves christian dogs as they were
called in arabic occupied a rung on the
social ladder somewhere well beneath
camels and probably donkeys and at one
point captain james riley was traded for
an old blanket just to give you an idea
of how much they were valued
several of the slaves were lost into the
interior of the continent and uh never
were heard from or seen again
doomed to live out their lives in
bondage though their lives would have
been mercifully short you could only
live so long when you're being used as a
pack animal in the desert and forced to
subsist on snails and camel urine which
is what they were consuming most of the
time
but riley and a few of his men managed
to escape with the assistance of a
comparatively merciful arab who ransomed
them for several hundred dollars and a
couple of muskets
yet the survivors never escaped the
physical or mental trauma of their
experiences and most of them died
relatively young but two of them
including riley did publish books about
their experiences and both books were
sensations at the time that they were
published
captain james riley would become a
household name
even abraham lincoln named his book
sufferings in africa as one of his
greatest inspirations
the funny thing though is that
this incredible and true tale which was
once widely known and renowned across
the country
has faded into obscurity in recent years
in fact the author of a skeletons on the
zahara dean king
only found out about the story and
decided to write a book about it after
stumbling across an old
dusty leather-bound copy of riley's
memoir while researching another book at
the new york yacht club library in 1995.
it's the only reason he even knew about
this
so why don't more people know about this
story why isn't it taught in schools
why haven't there been movies made based
on it is an incredible story
the book was actually adapted as a
screenplay before it was even published
with dreamworks attached back in like
2001
but the film was never made and then
five years or rather 10 years later in
2010 another screenplay was written but
that project also fizzled out
movie was never made
there's no mystery here of course this
story has fallen into the cracks of
history because it touches the tip of an
iceberg
that our educational establishment the
media and hollywood would all prefer
that we not acknowledge or explore
and that would be the subject of white
slaves in africa
riley and his men were not the only ones
not by a long shot in fact over the
course of a few centuries well over a
million white people were enslaved in
northern africa
a million
some of them detained and enslaved after
being shipwrecked but the vast majority
were abducted right off of ships still
at sea or from coastal european
communities by muslim raiders who
carried them back to africa to be sold
traded or ransomed
in some cases entire communities
coastal european communities were
ransacked
hundreds of people captured at one time
you know the united states fought a
whole war a series of them the barbary
wars to put a stop to this practice
there's a reason though that school
curricula tends to skip over that
conflict going from you know the
revolutionary war to the war of 1812 to
the civil war hop skipping and jumping
over some of these more uncomfortable
and troublesome episodes
there's a concerted effort in our
society to erase ignore and cover up
not just the story of white slaves in
africa but almost the entire global
history of slavery in general
the impression that we're supposed to
have is that the transatlantic slave
trade
white westerners enslaving africans
which was actually only a small piece of
the transatlantic slave trade but that's
the only form of slavery that ever
existed that's the impression we're
supposed to have
black africans were the victims white
americans and europeans were the
villains
end of story
and this is indeed what many people
believe because that is what our culture
wants them to believe
this point was driven home when i posted
a thread about the true history of
slavery to twitter on saturday thinking
about all these issues you know after
having just finished the book
i posted this this is what i said
well over one million whites were
enslaved in northern africa between the
16th and 19th centuries most of them
abducted and sold by muslim pirates
africans were raiding europe for slaves
for hundreds of years the school system
has totally erased this fact from
history
continuing of course white people were
enslaved in other parts of africa too
and across the world for centuries
including in north america where white
servants quote unquote were shipped to
the colonies by the thousands slaver in
america didn't begin in 1619 white
children were being kidnapped and sold
into servitude in the colonies before
that and of course slavery existed in
americas for hundreds of years prior to
europeans ever setting foot there indian
tribes all practiced slavery slavery
persisted in non-western countries long
after it had been abolished in the west
slavery was an accepted institution in
africa and asia for millennia and it
seems to have never occurred to any of
these societies there might have been
something wrong with the practice and of
course the african slave trade was
mostly furnished by africans capturing
other africans and selling them into
bondage the african slave trade was
abolished by the west
not by africa
slavery remained legal in parts of
africa well into the 20th century
actually i should have said that slavery
was uh
abolished
against the not just uh you know without
the help of the non-western world but
against the objections of the
non-western world was the slave trade
abolished
everything i wrote there is as true as
it is unknown to the average american
but predictably the outrage mob has been
screaming at me for the past two days
because of this calling me a nazi
accusing me of excusing or justifying or
minimizing the enslavement of black
people
accusing me of upholding white supremacy
quote unquote
my messages and emails have been as you
can imagine even more colorful
than that
but the attacks have um
come from the right as well this is not
all from the left
maj toure is a prominent gun rights
activist um maybe you've seen him on fox
news maybe you've seen him on youtube he
launched into a tirade that included
many tweets and several videos about me
beginning with this response he said
dumb reductive and horrible attempt at
justifying the transatlantic slave trade
take here
conservatives love going full [ __ ] and
damaging any inroads into black
communities with these kind of takes i
just big up dude for the what is a woman
film and then this
yes how dare i say something he
disagrees with after he just said he
likes my movie i should have known that
his endorsement of my film puts me in
debt to him for life i didn't realize
that
others on the right agreed with him
including aja smith who's a gop
congressional candidate who tweeted maj
was correct for calling him out far too
long folks are silent when they see and
hear a wrong
that's why we're in this disinformation
that we're in
now despite my urging i could not get
smith to explain what part of my
statement was disinformation
most of the people angry at me for
talking about this issue could not even
begin to explain
didn't try to explain how or why i'm
wrong
there was at least one exception well
known twitch streamer to the extent that
any twitch streamer can be called well
known hassan [ __ ] tried to debunk at
least one of the things that i said
about slavery let's listen to that
attempt
matt walsh well over 1 million whites
were enslaved in north africa between
the 16th and 19th centuries most of them
abducted and sold by muslim pirates
africans were raiding europe for slaves
for hundreds of years the school system
has totally erased this fact from
history first of all
uh
you know the glories of of uh
muslim
pirates doing that was erased probably
because the western world was
embarrassed by the l that they held
most likely to the ottoman empire most
frequently to the ottoman empire the
sick man of europe
okay
um
of course white people were enslaved in
other parts of africa too and across the
world for centuries including in north
america where white servants were
shipped to the colonies by the thousands
uh uh matt walsh is doing the classic
like uh chattel slavery is the same as
indentured servitude which of course
it's not indentured servitude in and of
itself is of course still completely
unacceptable uh obviously uh but uh the
main difference is in that situation is
that you can actually purchase
uh your way you can purchase your
freedom not that it's like super likely
or whatever but you can do that where
there was no purchasing of your freedom
as a as a black slave okay
um your child was immediately also seen
as property whereas indentured servitude
doesn't work that way as well and that's
precisely why
that's precisely why there is a
difference between uh the way that like
irishmen
or the way that italians or the way that
like whoever we're talking about in this
situation were able to uh to to
assimilate or welcome uh be welcomed
into white society in comparison to
black people which matt walsh of course
still doesn't want to uh welcome into
white society so there you go
[Music]
now we're going to be generous and
ignore the part where he refers to the
glories his words of muslims enslaving
white people he considers that a glory
and instead we're going to focus on his
claims about indentured servitude
this is totally different from chattel
slavery he says
and i've heard a lot of this you hear a
lot of this this attempt to distinguish
chattel slavery from other kinds of
slavery well in the west there was
chattel slavery which is so much worse
than all the other kinds of slavery well
chattel just means property right so um
chattel slavery is when the slave is
property well that's slavery that's the
definition of slavery is when someone is
made property
so there is no
coherent distinction to be made between
slavery and chattel slavery this is just
what people do when they're when they in
fact are looking to minimize or justify
one type of slavery and uh separate it
from other types
it's in the indentured servitude thing
he says well this is very different but
that's also incorrect in a book called
white cargo the forgotten history of
britain's white slaves in america
authors don jordan and michael walsh
explain no relation by the way as far as
know that in most cases an indentured
servant so-called was simply a slave by
another name
the servants were bought sold and traded
like any other slave like any other
property
and though their period of bondage was
supposed to be temporary oftentimes they
were kept in servitude for life after
their sentence was complete because
there was no one around to enforce the
terms of the deal
many others were worked to death long
before they could be freed many of these
quote-unquote dentures servants when
they were shipped to the americas died
within a year
because they were worked to death
they were worked harder than you worked
your livestock
also as the authors explained many of
the servants did not choose that
arrangement at all kids were kidnapped
off the street and sold into servitude
others were coaxed there on false
pretenses and then enslaved
so yes there were white slaves in
america there were a lot of them
as a new york times review of white
cargo says in its concluding sentence
this again is the new york times which
wrote this
this but this was 15 years ago there are
probably tens of millions of americans
who are descended from white slaves
without even knowing it
you don't often hear that brought up in
the reparations conversation do you
now the fact that white people were
slaves should not come as a surprise
anyway given that the word slaves comes
from slav because slavic people
historically were so often enslaved
was the enslavement of black people in
america completely different in its
barbarity from all other forms of
slavery across the world and throughout
history no
we've already discussed the conditions
of white slaves in africa and of white
children abducted and shipped to america
and then literally work to death what we
see very quickly from any honest study
of the history of slavery is that it was
unspeakably brutal
in all of its forms
galley slaves on arab ships were kept in
chains for years at a time not allowed
to leave the ship
and then if a british patrol approached
and they thought that the slaves were
going to be liberated they would just
cut their throats and throw them throw
them overboard
slaves in the americas before the
arrival of europeans that is slaves
owned by native american tribes because
they all owned slaves were frequently
tortured and brutalized especially in
mesoamerica where they often would be
gutted dismembered and sometimes
cannibalized during religious rituals
it was not good to be a slave anywhere
let's just say maybe we could leave it
at that
america was not unique in its
relationship with slavery
it wasn't even unique in its
exploitation of the transatlantic slave
trade most slaves from africa were
shipped not to the u.s but to the middle
east and south america
what makes the usa different from most
countries is not that it had slaves
in that fact it's on the same footing as
literally every other country that had
existed on earth until that point but
that it had slaves for such a
comparatively short amount of time
but does this matter
i mean should we be talking about any of
this
well yes it matters it matters because
it's true
and it's a truth that a lot of people
aren't aware of
and it matters because we cannot study
history
and most importantly learn from it
if we're determined to only look at
little pieces of the bigger stories
that's why it matters most of all
america slavery was not america's sin or
the western world's sin it was the
entire world's sin
one that the western world ultimately
did far more to stamp out and rectify
than anyone else
this is the entire world i mean for
thousands of years it's not just that
slavery existed for thousands of years
it that it's that for thousands of years
across the world
it hardly even occurred to anyone even
some of the even some of the greatest
philosophical and religious thinkers for
thousands of years across the world
hardly even occurred to anyone to that
there might be something wrong with the
practice in and of itself
there are people who spoke out against
the conditions of slaves against the
abuse of slaves but very
it's very very rarely did you hear
anyone even get close
to criticizing slavery as an institution
this was a massive
moral blind spot
that virtually everyone who existed on
earth for thousands of years shared
that's an important story
that there could be a blind spot like
that
that everyone shares
something we should probably talk about
and think about and learn from
because as i said it's the truth
and the thing about the truth is that uh
the more you tell me not to say it
the louder i'll be about it
that's the way it works
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know nobody likes to spend money
in general but especially not on your
cards you buy it you drive it you want
it to run forever maintenance free but
that's just not the way things work snap
out of it get a clue cars require upkeep
the same way your house requires them
the good news is that you can maintain
your car for less
than you can expect when you shop for
auto parts at rockauto.com chain stores
have different price tiers you know for
professional mechanics do-it-yourselfers
but rock autos uh prices are always the
same for everybody and they're reliably
low for everybody all the time
rockauto.com has been in the auto parts
business for 20 years family owned their
goals to make auto parts available and
affordable to keep you safe on the road
every day they've got everything you
might need from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps they've
got motor oil they've got new carpet
whatever it is they've got it whether
it's for your classic or daily driver
get everything you need and a few easy
clicks delivered right to your door the
rockauto.com catalog is remarkably easy
to navigate quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brand specifications and prices you
prefer they've got amazing selections
they've got reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need so what
are you waiting for go to rockauto.com
get breaks shocks carpets wipers
everything at rockauto.com be sure to
write walsh in their how did you hear
about us box so they know that i sent
you
um this this you know this is just this
is how it goes you tell me to stop
talking about it i do a 15 minute
monologue about it to start the week
that's just the way this works and uh in
fact that ended up
um
that ended up
superseding what i was going to start
the show with today originally which was
the issue of student loans because
there's a couple of things going on
on that issue that are really that are
important so first of all we have this
from from npr it says a new report from
the u.s government accountability office
finds the us department of education
miscalculated the cost of the federal
student loan program
miscalculated is a
generous understatement let's say from
1997 to to 2021 the education department
estimated that payments from federal
direct student loans would generate
100 and bill 114 billion dollars for the
government
but the government accountability office
found that as of 2021 the program had
actually cost the government an
estimated 197
billion dollars
a percentage of that shortfall 102
billion stems from the unprecedented
federal student loan payment pause that
began under the cares act of 2020. the
pause has been extended several times
under uh former president trump and
president biden the most recent
extension runs through august 31st
a bigger reason for the 311 billion
dollar difference report says is that
initial predictions did not account for
the high percentage of borrowers who
ended up enrolling an income driven
repayment plans
about half of all direct loans are now
paid through these plans which are
designed to help people who can't afford
to make large monthly payments and which
promise loan cancellation after 20 to 25
years
so what do we learn from this first of
all the department of education is
incompetent useless should not exist
and it's really bad at estimating the
costs of things
to the extent of estimating a 114
billion dollar windfall that in reality
becomes a nearly 200 billion dollar loss
a money pit
and that should make you really nervous
about this this is a story from business
insider says the education department is
ready to cancel student debt once
president joe biden gives the word
according to politico on thursday
politico released a report detailing
internal memos within the education
department on plans to carry out broad
student loan forgiveness biden has
considered moving to cancel ten thousand
dollars in student debt for borrowers
making under 150 000
and the report says the department is
prepared to provide that relief within
months of any announcement for borrowers
whose income information is available
borrowers with borrowers without income
information readily readily available to
the department would apply through a
form on
studentaid.gov to self-certify their
income and qualifications for relief per
the report so the private education is
ready to do this the um the most recent
student loan pause as it said is is up
at the end of uh this month that just
began
so either biden is going to kick the can
down the road some more and pause it
again which i wouldn't be surprised if
he does because he's just going to keep
pausing until we get to the midterms
which at this point would take i think
one more pause and you're past the
midterms or he's going to
institute some sort of student loan
forgiveness
now on this issue of um
student debt and so-called forgiveness
which is a euphemism that i'm using
myself because i'm reading it in these
articles but it is we should keep in
mind it is a euphemism
because it's actually not possible this
is not something that anyone has a magic
wand where they can wave it and say oh
you are forgiven
go in peace my child you are absolved of
your debts
now as i always point out this is not
student loan forgiveness it is student
loan transferal it is debt transferal
not debt forgiveness
all debt forgiveness is debt transferal
because somebody is left holding the bag
someone has to pay the debt it's just a
matter of who is it going to be
um
and on that topic of who it's going to
be i thought this poll from uh nina
turner who's uh i don't know she's a
leftist mouthpiece she has a blue check
on twitter so she must be important she
was um she sent out this poll
about student debt and she obviously
wanted it to go a certain way
the way she phrases the poll she says
should the president cancel student debt
and then the options are
no people should suffer
yes
ten thousand dollars yes fifty thousand
dollars or cancel all of it in
exclamation points
now she's phrased it that way because
obviously she's hoping that everyone
will hit on hit the cancel all of it
option there
i mean obviously when you phrase it no
people should suffer
uh no one's gonna click on that but in
fact people did so
what she ended up with is almost 69 of
the respondents of her poll
answered no people should suffer
and
i actually even though this was not
intentional
and the way she phrased it was meant to
skew the results in favor of debt
forgiveness
i actually love the way she phrased it
because inadvertently she brings up a
good point
and it's a question of
who should suffer
and when you answer no you know when you
say no he should the president should
not cancel student debt
you're saying no people should suffer
but not just people in general
it's that the people who took out the
loans
should suffer because of those loans
yes that's my that's my position
and if that sounds cruel or or uncaring
or how could you think that people
should suffer
from the consequences of the choices
they made
well because and look i would love it if
nobody ever had to suffer ever again
that's that would be my preference
so if that was the poll
um you know
if there was a poll where we could click
a certain option or press a button and
no one ever has to suffer again then
then i would take that option
but unfortunately we live in reality
and that's never the option in reality
so really it's a question of not whether
people should suffer but who should
suffer there's some suffering that's
going to happen
it just is
who's going to have to carry that burden
there there is a cross that has to be
carried someone's going to have to carry
it who's it going to be well there are
two options
either
the mostly upper
class college graduates who took out
these loans can suffer because of them
you know that's one option
or
the people who didn't take out the loans
can suffer
because of the loans that the upper
class college grads took out
people who took out the loans suffer or
the people who didn't suffer
and another way you could break this
down is that you know upper class
college grads can suffer or middle class
working class people can suffer
and of those two options yeah the people
who took out the loans should do the
suffering for the choices that they made
the person who should suffer from the
mistake is the person who made it
yes definitely
that's um there's not much to even think
about there
and let's make no mistake about this
that
if
we have student debt quote unquote
forgiveness
yeah it might be it might be a temporary
relief for the people who you know just
look and oh my debt's gone away
but there's gonna be a lot of suffering
because of it
i mean that money is gonna come from
somewhere
and as much as the democrats might claim
oh it's gonna come from billionaires
no it's going to come from the working
class because it always does
they're always the ones who end up
holding the bag
and then there are other consequences
too like
inflation
okay
in inflation that um is already causing
much suffering
and now you're talking about canceling
all student debt now now inflation is
that is that going to help inflation or
hurt it
is that going to help us in battling
inflation or is that going to hurt us is
the question
so this would mean suffering for a lot
of people and it would mean suffering
for the people who did not make that
choice to begin with
this is just it's it's uh
it's not a fun reality in fact i i am
sympathetic
i'm sympathetic to the people
who took out these loans because they
were duped into it and they were
convinced
you know by the education system by
their high school guidance counselors by
their own parents by the media by
everybody
by the college you know by the
university system especially that they
have to take out these loans and
purchase this really expensive piece of
paper purchase the degree because if
they don't then they're going to be
failures and they're never going to have
any chance at success in life
that's a lie
it's a scam but uh there were a lot of
people that were duped into it and i
feel bad for those people i'm very
sympathetic to them
but
my sympathy dries up the moment you take
your hand and try to reach into somebody
else's pocket
okay
the moment you try to offload your
suffering onto someone else
that's when my sympathy goes away just
like that it's gone it evaporates i have
none left for you
now if you are carrying this burden with
uh some stoicism
you know if you're if you're carrying it
with some courage and strength and
saying that like this is really really
hard
and it's not fair
and i was lied to
and i paid six figures for this stupid
piece of paper which has done nothing
for me
but you carry it because there's no
other choice and the last thing you're
going to do is expect anyone else to
carry it for you you know if you do that
then all the sympathy in the world
there's just no there is no magic wand
way around this
what we can start thinking about and
talking about is what do we do going
forward
because we're left with this really
difficult situation
um and it's a very unfair situation
for a lot of people it's just that you
know yes i think it's it is it is unfair
i mean the idea like 18 years old you
can make a choice like this these 18
year old kids don't know what they're
doing
so it is unfair it's just that it
becomes even more unfair so if it's
already unfair in many ways
to expect people who took out these
loans when they're 18 to pay them back
how much more unfair is it to expect
people who never took out the loans to
pay them back
but if we want to rectify the unfair
situation in the future
what we have to do
is start telling people the truth start
telling kids the truth
you don't need to go to college
it's not just that college is
unnecessary it is that it is a it is in
many cases malignant
and the college the university system's
overall effect on the culture has been
generally malignant for decades now
you can just sidestep that completely
and go off and have a lot of success in
life it is possible
and the really great thing is that if
you do if you do just
leap right over this thing that they
told this step they told you you had to
take
and you go off and you live your life
down the line when you're
when you're older and you actually have
some financial means if you decide that
you actually do want to go to college
you still can it'll still be there for
you
that's the truth we should be telling
okay
so from the daily wire it says um well
first of all thursday night was the um
the congressional
baseball game where
republicans won 10-0
and which is which is pretty funny
already of course it was only five years
ago that republicans were attacked
during a baseball during a baseball game
by a crazed bernie bro who went there
with a hit list
intent on murdering gop lawmakers
and um so you might think that
given that history that this would be
you know a congressional baseball game
is a time for displays of unity and
brotherly love
you might think that if you're brain
damaged but if not you're not surprised
to see this representative linda sanchez
a democrat from california
after i believe striking out we can only
assume she's uh walking by the gop
dugout and then she does this let's play
this clip here she she flips them off as
she walks by lead off the inning we'll
get a pinch runner down there the fist
bump
we'll get an eye on who the pinch runner
is going to be looks like it's going to
be jeffries
and she will come off to a nice ovation
well not much reaction from the
okay
flip off there
so
okay i might have been on fair tour i
guess i i take from the context there
that she she did she did get a hit but
then she had a pinch she has someone
running for her she has a pinch runner
no big surprise there
but she she goes by the dugout and she
just flips off the republicans
this is like this is a lawmaker
right this is someone who's suppose
there was a time when you expected
there's never been a time when when
politics was anything but a rough and
tumble sport but there was a time when
you would expect
some measure of
decorum and dignity and statesmanship
from your elected leaders
even when they were pummeling each other
over the head when you know when
arguments in congress became physically
violent
still there was some dignity and decorum
to it
now we just don't expect that at all so
it's not a surprise to see that
but here's her excuse from the daily
wire she said says democrat
representative linda sanchez claimed in
a statement friday afternoon that she
flipped off the republican dugout during
thursday night's congressional baseball
game because she heard a sexist remark
being made as she ran back to the
democrats dugout
the statement read the congressional
baseball game is one of my favorite
events of the year it's a great cause
and brings both sides of the aisle
together for a night off from partisan
politics that's why i really struck a
nerve when i heard an offensive and
misogynistic comment from the republican
side on my way back to the dugout
so there was a it was an offensive and
misogynistic comment that was made to
her she doesn't say what the comment was
and um i guess being very charitable she
never meant she never says who who said
it
well this excuse didn't really land and
that's why a day later she clarified the
story yet again this is from red state
it says now sanchez is clarifying her
story again she's now saying it wasn't
the republican team that made the
comment
she says quote it wasn't the team it was
an obnoxious fan who shouts misogynistic
s at me every single year
uh but she still went after republican
she says actually they you know she's
the victim here she says if the
republican women would have stood up and
said that's not accep acceptable instead
of you know trashing me for my response
then we might have a place where there's
no misogyny that's tolerated by anybody
anywhere
and yet
amid all these excuses that she's
offering
uh she still has not she's not told us
what the comment was
and she even says well it wasn't now you
know it wasn't it wasn't the republican
wasn't the actual republicans themselves
it was someone on their side up in the
in the stands who made the comment but
she knows who the guy is
because she says he's there every year
but very nice of her to not mention his
name
because democrats are known for that
right of course
they're very reticent to throw anybody
under the bus to name names to send the
outrage mob after anybody they never do
that kind of thing
all right this is uh moving on this is
new york post it says there's a chance
the identity of the winner of the 1.3
billion mega millions jackpot will never
be known thanks to an illinois law
allowing people who score more than 250
000 to keep their name secret
the winning ticket to the mind-boggling
fortune was sold at the speedy cafe
speedway gas station um according to
lottery officials
and uh but no one yet has come forward
to claim the price so that's the news
there's
the jackpot was up to 1.3 billion
dollars someone claimed it we still
don't know who this apparently is not
the highest
jackpot that the lottery's ever had 1.5
billion dollars one and a half billion
dollars in the lottery that somebody won
back in 2018 and we still don't know who
that person was either
probably a smart move to not tell people
who you are if you win a billion dollars
in the lottery i only mention this
because
and i know this is one of those things
that for whatever reason nobody cares
about but
just just fyi you know
lotteries are one of the most
indefensible and dystopian things that
we all take for granted
we all just kind of accept that the
lottery exists and lots of people like
it and they think it's a lot of fun
um
but this is an actual gambling ring
run by the government
and in the case of the mega millions
it's a i guess a consortium of a
consortium of of of state governments
but however they
divvy it up this is the government state
governments um governmental powers that
are running a gambling ring
and and this happens even as many other
forms of private gambling are banned
in some states in fact i think there's
at least i don't know there's several i
don't know how many five six maybe uh
states where the only form of gambling
that's allowed is that which the
government runs and profits off of
so they've banned all forms of gambling
you know you can't do sports gambling
there's no slot machines there's no
casinos you can't bet on cards you can't
bet on anything
oh but they have the lottery though you
can bet on that
and that's by the way the one form of
gambling where you're the least likely
to win
that's that's the worst form
it's just as addictive as if not more so
any other form of gambling but the
difference is that unlike with sports
betting you could actually get good at
it and uh and win money consistently i
know people who do uh but with gant with
the lottery there's no way to
master it and eventually win
consistently
and yet that's the one kind that's
allowed in a lot of states
and the reason that they give just add
insult to injury
the reason given for banning these other
forms of gambling in other states is uh
they always give moral reasons they say
well gambling is bad you shouldn't be
doing it it's harmful it's addictive
and yet the very
agents of the government making this
argument are running their own gambling
ring
and what is the lottery it's of course
it's a tax on
the poor its attacks on ignorant people
its attacks on addicts
people who you know dump i mean we've
all we've all been at the gas station
standing behind some pathetic
sight of a person dumping like 90 and
you could tell it's this is like this is
their gas money and and grocery bill for
the week and dumping it all into
scratch-offs
or
jackpot lottery tickets
and the thing is you're never going to
win
almost certainly
and if you do win it's worse than not
winning because it's almost certain to
destroy your life
like it's one thing to hit it big on
sports betting but to just
take someone
some average person and hand them like
900 million dollars
is uh that's
almost a death sentence
it's going to
rip their lives apart uh they're going
to die of an overdose all the rest of
them we've seen that many many times
yeah it's just one of the i guess
because there there are so many corrupt
and inexcusable and indefensible things
that the government does you have to you
have to pick your spots a little bit
and so i guess we kind of
kind of gloss over this one maybe which
maybe is somewhat understandable i also
wanted to mention this this is from espn
um news hot off the presses here it says
cleveland browns quarterback deshaun
watson will serve a six-game suspension
for violating the league's personal
conduct policy following accusations of
sexual misconduct
so
if you haven't followed this story at
all
um
desean watson is a
superstar quarterback now for the
cleveland browns after being traded from
the houston texans
and now he's going to get a six-game
suspension
and this is after being accused of
um
of sexual assault by i think we're up to
26 women
all of them massage therapists so it's
the same story they all tell
where they were either assaulted or you
know harassed in very graphic ways while
giving deshaun watson a massage
and what we know about him is that he
has is that while he was in houston he
cycled through like 40 different
masseuses over the course of like a year
or two
that's a normal thing isn't it
26 women come out and say this is what
happened to them
and now he's facing a six-game
suspension
no monetary fine either
being added on top of that
and this is where you know
it's important to distinguish between a
lot of the me too stuff and something
like this
because during the height of the metoo
hysteria
there were plenty of men
who suffered far worse consequences
while being accused of things not nearly
as bad as this
but this is what me too does is one one
thing it does is that it you know kind
of just discredits everybody all at once
anyone who makes an accusation is
discredited
and in this case yeah it's there isn't
any physical evidence because of the
nature of the accusation that
if if he did physically sexually assault
or harass someone during a massage there
would what kind of physical evidence
could there possibly be of that
and so all you're left with is the
accusations but 26
now it's true just because one woman
comes out and accuses a famous man of
doing something doesn't mean he did it
if another woman comes out and and
corroborates and said same thing
happened to me doesn't mean it's true
another woman comes out also doesn't
mean it's true but at a certain point
when you get into the 20s
uh you do have to stop and think like
there's something going on here
this is not a problem that anybody else
has
lots of guys go get massages and uh
none of them have ever been accused of
25 women of sexual harassment
and yet interestingly enough um
even though there are plenty of men at
the height of the metoo hysteria
who are accused of far less
had far less evidence against them
because 25 accusations i mean that is a
form of evidence right that's that's
testimony against you
uh and yet suffered far worse
repercussions
i wonder why that is
all right one other thing i want to
mention uh before we get to the comment
section
this is from live science it's that
explorers have discovered a series of
mysterious perfectly aligned holes
punched into the sea floor roughly 1.6
miles beneath the ocean surface and they
have no idea who or what made them the
strange holes were spotted by the crew
of the national oceanic and atmospheric
administration's explorer vessel as they
investigated the mid-atlantic ridge a
mostly unexplored region of the sea
floor that is part of the world's
largest mountain range the holes formed
a straight line and appear to regularly
repeating distances and they are
surrounded by tiny mounds of sediment
and no one knows exactly where these
holes came from what's so fascinating
about this
as i once again try to convince you to
care about a science story
what's fascinating is how little we
actually know about our oceans and
what's happening in them eighty percent
of the world's oceans remain unexplored
that's because the oceans are so vast
obviously but also they're so
inhospitable to
if not life in general then at least us
because deep down in the ocean
it's extremely dark and cold the water
pressure if you go all the way down to
the deepest part of the of the marianas
trench six or seven miles down you're
talking about 15 000 pounds of pressure
per square inch which is the equivalent
of having like a bunch of tanks or
cement trucks stacked on top of you
and yet there are all kinds of life
forms living deep in the ocean anyway
who are able to survive in those
conditions and we don't know anything
about most of them
and who knows what else is going on down
there
like i said eighty percent unexplored
seventy percent of the of the earth is
covered in oceans eighty percent of that
seventy percent is unexplored we have no
idea what's going on
who are who knows
who or what made those holes
we may never know
but it was probably aliens
is the point i was getting to ultimately
let's get now to the comment section
[Applause]
[Music]
sprint kick says this human filing
cabinet would be something seen on mars
where the atmosphere is totally
unsustainable for human life the fact
that the elites think this would be a
good idea here really illustrates their
contempt for humanity
is referring to the city of the future
that we talked about on on thursday's
show
and this is something that they're
supposedly going to build in saudi
arabia and then they and then they hope
to export it to other countries
including our own
was just a long they call it the line
but really it's just a long vast
rectangle where they want to stuff all
of the people and you would live there
between these mirrored walls your whole
life and never leave
um and yeah it does it does kind of
remind you of what you would put on a
planet if it was
a total wasteland that couldn't sustain
human life
and the other point there is that
mars and venus
are are you know you mentioned mars
venus as well
good case studies
i think in the sort of inevitable course
of all planets
because because both of them were once
like earth you know they had oceans and
atmospheres and everything probably had
life on them
but now they're barren wastelands
and it's not because
anybody was driving suvs on those
planets three billion years ago as far
as we know
but just because this is the course of
nature
this is the course of the universe
and it's inevitable
and there's nothing you can really do to
stop it
zachary todd says i'm glad someone else
is finally calling out the bs [ __ ]
just randomly went from being normal to
being a slur without any explanation
well it's like i said there's this
absurd idea that the comfort level of
the speaker
when it comes to speaking right the
comfort level of you as the speaker
doesn't matter it's only the comfort
level of the person hearing whatever
you're saying that matters
which doesn't make any sense to me so
some people for whatever reason feel
more comfortable hearing little people
than [ __ ] which which is fine if
that's what they prefer
and if that's what they want to say but
i don't feel more comfortable saying
that
it feels weird to me to say little
people instead of [ __ ] and since i'm
the one speaking
shouldn't it be up to me what words i
use based on my own comfort level based
on what feels right to me
um and he says matt to this day i reject
i regret objecting when my husband tried
to confront some pervert who came into
the ladies room my marriage would be
better today if i just sat quietly and
let him deck the guy we've come to a
point in our culture where women don't
know how to be protected any more than
men know how to protect us i think
that's a
really important insight there
it's not just um
men losing the instincts and the ability
the desire the will to protect women
but on the other side of it
you know women should allow themselves
to be protected by men so both of these
things are happening all at once
um mike says i'm roughly the same age as
matt and i remember in elementary school
believing that if aids didn't get me
would be the acid rain
those were the childhood propaganda of
our time
yeah um and we've talked about you know
if we've been over this the the uh
especially in the 90s if you if you
made the mistake of going to elementary
school in the 90s which at least is
better than going to elementary school
now but um there are a lot of things you
didn't have to deal with in the 90s in
elementary school that kids today do
have to deal with
but one of the big things in the 90s in
elementary school is that you were told
about aids and you were told that anyone
can get it and you like basically just
walking past someone in the hallway you
can contract aids and i do always uh
wonder
if all of this aids
propaganda and paranoia
being you know shoved into the minds of
kids in the 90s if that has helped to
turn us into
you know hypochondriacs
and then when you get to the coveted
panic and the way that especially my
generation has reacted to it many of
them still walking around with masks on
you know is it because of like the
mental conditioning that started way
back 30 years ago i do wonder that
uh and finally another comment says i
think it's really hard to fall in deep
and genuine love with anyone if you
don't like them even a little bit on the
outside we have to be honest men and yes
women too do take looks into
consideration even if they don't want to
admit it we need to stop going by the
exceptions to the rule those who don't
take even a small amount of looks into
consideration it's not just a matter of
taking looks into consideration right
your looks are
part of who you are it's
it's how the other person knows you it's
how they experience your
presence
um your physical body is not just a
container we aren't hermit crabs living
in shells right now the difference for
women is that their perception
of your physical attractiveness is
more determined by
aspects of you that are not physical
so like if a woman finds you smart and
and thinks that you're kind and generous
and funny especially funny then she'll
begin to perceive you as more physically
attractive
even if in reality you look like a giant
toad
and that's very good for men
because without this advantage we would
most of us probably
die alone
all right so this is the moment in the
show where in years past i would have
read you an ad for harry's razors i
would have said something like hey you
millions of listeners i love harry's go
out and buy one
uh but i'm not gonna do that because i
don't love harry's i hate harry's in
fact if you don't know the story by now
harry's used to advertise on our shows
until someone here said that boys our
boys and girls are girls if you can
imagine the horror of a statement like
that this was too much for our sponsor
who pulled their ads due to values
misalignment
well we're not going to promote products
that um hate your values so we did the
only thing that made sense to us we
launched our own razer company jeremy's
razors every jeremy's razor's kit comes
with a premium razor two sets of blades
shaving cream and aftershave balm it's a
beautiful thing to behold and over 70
000 kits have shipped already people uh
love this product for good reason you
can see why so instead of telling you
that i'm a big fan of harry's i'm here
to to uh tell you about the thousands of
ex harry's fans who've literally thrown
their razors in the trash and switched
to jeremy's and they're not going back i
can tell you go to i hate harry's dot
com and get your jeremy's razors
founder's kit it's time to stop giving
your money to what corporations that
hate you
give to jeremy instead now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel mary katherine starr who
is the artist podcaster consultant
professional yoga instructor with
pronouns in her bio though that last
detail i'm sure would
already have been assumed who's amassed
a large online following through her
viral comics depicting motherhood
as she sees it
now if you spend any time on social
media you may have already encountered
one or two or 20 of these mom life
comics where star
shares her relatable insights into
marriage relatable to her anyway and i
suppose to the band of bitter sullen
women who follow her and share her
content it becomes clear rather quickly
after glancing at her work that star
really does not enjoy motherhood very
much doesn't like her husband very much
and is now attempting to make her
resentment seem
inspirational
much of it centers around as a glowing
profile in huffington post explains the
unfair ways that society views moms
versus dads
except that these viral comics often
seem less relevant to society and more
based on whatever petty gripe she has
about her husband on any particular day
for example
one of her recent offerings which has
circulated widely on social media is
captioned
one of the many differences between me
and my husband
in one panel we see her staring at a
peach on the table and the thought
bubble says oh look the last ripe peach
i'll save it for the kids they love
peaches so much
the next panel shows her husband and his
thought bubble says oh look the last
ripe peach i'll use it as a special
treat in my daily smoothie
now surely your husband deserves this
public shaming for having the audacity
to eat the food in his own house
and he gets shamed for many other things
too in another comic this one with
nearly 20 000 likes on instagram she
tells us the saga
of her husband having trouble finding
things
it says we're sitting down to eat
breakfast my husband is still in the
kitchen i say will you grab a bib for
teddy he says where are the bibs
what i want to say in response is
they're in the same place they've been
for the past five years in the same
place i put them every time i watched
them and put them away presumably the
same place you've gotten them from a
thousand times before unless of course
you've never gotten either one of our
kids a bib in the past five years
but what i actually say in the corner
cabinet the same place they've always
been
and that my friends is called
self-control
nothing like bitching about your spouse
publicly while also congratulating
yourself for being passive-aggressive
oftentimes she seems to make no attempt
to be humorous at all i'm being generous
in assuming that some of this is at
least supposed to be somewhat funny i
guess i don't know
and um
in these other cases she just simply
lectures her husband directly like this
one
uh it says me trying to explain our
household dynamics in terms my husband
understands
and then we see her saying on most
sports teams you have a superstar or a
playmaker who makes things happen that's
me
then you often have that one person who
just stands around waiting for other
people to make plays or shoot the ball
that's you
we need you to step up so we can win as
a team
now here we see the danger of making a
sports analogy when you've never watched
a single sporting event in your entire
life but we're going to return to that
in just a moment there are many other
examples we don't need to cycle through
she has comments complaining that her
husband doesn't carry as many grocery
bags from the car as she does
another where she complains that her
husband gets to work out alone while she
has to work out with her kids draped all
draped all over her she complains that
um
once he wore a winter hat that was hers
without her permission she has a whole
comic about that she complains that uh
he takes up too much room on the couch
when he naps he complains that she
complains that um he uh he gets to nap
in the first place and she doesn't she
complains that he takes too long to run
errands she has many comments
complaining that her husband spends too
much time going to the bathroom this is
a theme she returns to over and over
again
her husband's defecation habits have
been thoroughly chronicled by this woman
she even has a father's day card that
she's created which centers around this
theme it says
this father's day take as much time as
you need in the bathroom oh wait that's
you every day so this father's day take
as much time as you need in the bathroom
and i promise not to say anything about
it well i'll try my very best
while this is passive-aggressive is it
it's at least a little bit nicer than
the mother's day card that i wish her
husband would give to her sometime it
could say something like happy mother's
day being with you is at least better
than being fed feet first into a wood
chipper
though the wood chipper is looking
better every day
her husband we can assume lacks the
gumption to say anything like that to
her but others on the internet have
spoken up on his behalf suggesting that
maybe she should stop incessantly
whining publicly about her about her
marriage maybe this is something she
could do in counseling or something
in response to the critics this weekend
she murdered herself some more posting a
defiant response on instagram and
extensively quoting taylor swift lyrics
at the same time and she of course
chalked the criticism up to sexism and
said any that anyone who disagrees with
her approach will be blocked
which certainly is the least
intimidating threat ever issued in the
history of threats
but at the risk of maybe suffering the
same fate i want to offer some thoughts
to this woman
about her marriage i mean given that
she's talking publicly about it i guess
it's fair game
first of all um
i don't know how many of these
complaints accurately describe her
husband's behavior
there's no reason to think that any of
them are 100 fair
i i do know that
many of them certainly don't accurately
describe husbands in general as she
claims they do i've never met a man who
doesn't take immense pride in his
ability to transport an entire trunk
full of grocery bags into the kitchen in
one trip that's what men do that's like
we love doing that
as for having kids draped all over you
while exercising i actually encourage my
kids to do that to me because it adds
extra resistance and makes for a more
effective workout also puts them to good
use for a change
it might be true that men take longer to
complete one specific bathroom activity
but this is balanced out by the amount
of time that women take to do everything
else in the bathroom
and and do we as men have a habit of
forgetting where things are in the house
often staring helplessly at our own
kitchen cabinets and pantries as if this
is the first time we've ever laid eyes
on them
yes i mean that stereotype is i admit
richly deserved
but
here's the bigger question
so what
sure mary your husband isn't perfect
no husband is
all husbands are deeply and
irretrievably flawed
yes the rumors are true
as a wife
you will not be able to turn your
husband into a perfect specimen of
faultless humanity
you especially won't be able to
accomplish that by scolding nagging or
whining that approach always and i mean
always has the opposite effect
the only thing you can do
is decide
whether you will obsessively focus on
your husband's flaws or not
you have to decide
if you want to be a martyr
or simply a wife
a martyr or simply a mother
do you want to stew in the juices of
your own resentment constantly adding to
the broth with new groans and gripes
or do you want to actually be happy
and content
or at least have a chance of happiness
and contentment
are you going to be so resentful over
the chores you do around the house that
simply being around you becomes a chore
for everybody else
this is what you have the power to
control
and so does your husband for himself
because despite what you apparently
believe
your husband certainly has a whole
litany of complaints about you
he may not say them out loud very often
or post about them on the internet
because he respects you more than you
respect him but he has them
no husband is perfect yes but neither is
any wife
and that's especially true in your case
i wonder have you ever taken a break
during one of your
self-pity sessions
to reflect on the things that you might
be doing wrong
you've devoted hours and days and months
and years to thinking about talking
about crying about
screaming about all the many ways that
you're put upon oppressed unappreciated
but have you ever at any point
allowed for even one second of honest
self-reflection
if you feel that your husband is so
oblivious to his failings that you need
to point them out 75 times a day have
you considered the possibility
that you might suffer from the same
blind spot
or worse are you aware of your failings
and yet you justify them to yourself by
comparing them to your husband's
failings
and if this is the case and i'm certain
that it is have you considered that he
might be doing the same thing
perhaps your marriage is stuck in a
cycle of self-rationalization and
self-martyrdom and it will continue in
that circle
all the way around the drain
one other thought
your sports analogy was instructive but
not for the reason that you hoped
you say that there's always uh
the one guy on the team who stands
around doing nothing
now that might be true on amateur teams
like in little league or pop warner or
on the detroit lions but in the big
leagues everyone on the field or on the
court is involved
they all have a role
they're all doing something on every
play even if they appear to be doing not
much at all
so someone who doesn't understand
football might watch the action you know
from whistle to whistle and conclude
that the left tackle is mostly just a
spectator but those who know the game
understand that he has an indispensable
role to play even if it's less glamorous
less highlight-worthy
less praised
and even if he tends to only get his
name called when he screws up
in spite of that he's in the trenches on
every play filling a role that no one
else on the team could possibly fill
so i wonder if you might misinterpret
your marriage
in the same way that you misinterpret
football
just because you don't appreciate or
understand all the ways that your
husband contributes
that doesn't mean he isn't contributing
i mean this could be less a problem with
his effort and more a problem with your
self-centered refusal to even attempt to
see things from his perspective
you're the superstar the playmaker in
your own mind
and just like any other player who
elevates himself while denigrating his
team
you're doing more harm than good
you're destroying your team in fact
while telling yourself that you're the
only one helping it succeed
so i would recommend that you try
watching a game before saying anything
else about sports and also try looking
in the mirror
before saying anything else about your
marriage
but you don't have to look in the mirror
to know that you are today
still canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomlin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2022. hey
there this is john bickley daily wire
editor in chief and co-host of
morningwire on today's episode the biden
administration's response to economic
recession the impact of tick-tock on the
social media landscape and new evidence
related to hunter biden and his business
partners prompts calls for a special
counsel investigation
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire